we got him ladies and gentlemen donald
trump's
tax records have finally been
put in the hands of the new york
district attorney you might remember
that late last week the supreme court
made a decision
donald trump can't keep shielding his
tax returns
from the new york district attorney and
the grand jury that has been convened
donald trump has fought for years and it
has taken years to make this a reality
trump has fought for years to keep his
tax returns
secret why has he done it we don't know
presumably donald trump has made the
calculation maybe accurately
that what is in the tax returns getting
out is far
worse for him than the criticisms
for keeping the tax returns secret in
any case
prosecutors now have the tax returns as
of monday
they got them just hours after the
supreme court
said no to the trump final appeal
for keeping those records private this
includes millions of pages of documents
according to sources which include
trump's tax returns going from january
of 2011
to august of 2019 financial statements
um engagement agreements documents
relating to the preparation of his tax
returns
work papers communications related to
the tax returns and this is a
treasure trove of information now as a
reminder
none of this legally is to be released
to the public
the release of these tax returns and
other financial records
are two new york prosecutors
for the purposes of investigation and
use with the grand jury that has been
convened now
is it possible that these documents will
be leaked of course
of course i don't i'm not counting
significantly on that particularly when
it's widely known where they would have
come from
this is the only entity now that has had
these
documents uh turned over to them i think
that
the risk would be high of deliberately
leaking them uh could they leak in some
other way
yeah maybe maybe um at this point
it's less about at this point i don't
think even if they were to leak no
matter what's in them
i don't think it would have a
significant impact but
there is still sort of just a curiosity
that i have like
what is in them that is so bad that
donald trump didn't want them released
and we've speculated before
one of the revelations of trump's tax
returns
could be one that would simply affect
trump from the standpoint of vanity that
the tax returns may reveal that donald
trump is not
nearly as wealthy as he has claimed to
be and that would be a reason for trump
to want to keep them hidden
more for vanity than for any kind of
legal repercussions however
it is conceivable that these tax returns
would reveal even more deception from
donald trump
about the value of assets when it's
advantageous to inflate the value versus
when it's advantageous to downplay the
value
and it could get donald trump into
financial trouble uh it could expose
certain liabilities or other connections
that donald trump has although
much of that would really be in a
financial disclosure more than in tax
returns so there's still a question mark
as to what exactly
would be there but we simply won't know
if and until we actually get these
documents released so they are now in
the hands
of new york prosecutors once the supreme
court ruled it happened very very
quickly
and we will see ultimately if we learn
more about their contents i'm not
holding my breath
but i would be fascinated today's show
is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook called takeover how
a conservative student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audio book from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor
and constitutional scholar you may
remember him
from his prominent role in trump's
impeachment number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country six of the nine
current supreme court justices are
current or former members of the
federalist
society and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for its
relationship with american politics
the federalist society is an
organization
anyone in my audience should be aware of
and the audio book
has a ton of excellent insight into it
and the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover
by noah feldman the audiobook is just
4.99 and you can get it at
davidpakman.com
takeover or wherever you buy audiobooks